so thank you all for having me out today
and joining me for my talk again my name
is still Joe kinck and I'm here to talk
to yall about scaling your shiny apps
and some cool tools to do
that but before we get into that I'm
going to talk about something a little
different which is wreck League
Sports in these low stakes competitive
Arenas there's a number of player
archetypes that emerge but one that
shows up often is the overe
extender this person is putting it all
in the line on their team they're doing
everything everywhere all at once and
with an unrelenting fervor to boot we
love this player we appreciate what they
do but what's becomes apparent very
quickly is that they reach a point where
they're doing too much and their
performance just starts to get weird it
starts to lag and it can get pretty
weird at
times
and truth be told our shiny apps are
very much the same way you know the
process goes you develop a prototype you
share it with a particular team team
loves it word starts getting around
other teams begin to leverage your app
as well adoption continues to increase
but you reach a certain critical mass
where your shiny app is serving a lot of
these teams but the performance starts
to lag you know the complaints start to
roll in my plots are lagging or my
reports taking too long to run or you
just get that Spinning Wheel of death
that seems to be taking just a little
too
long so this talk okay this talk is
going to be a story about two things one
is going to be about a a toy app that
struggled to scale to a large number of
users and then we're also going to talk
about how we use JavaScript to augment
shiny to overcome that
struggle so this is the app that we
start with it's a very simple shiny
application with two interactive hexin
plots simple easy and
nice so with an app like this you know
what seems to be the issue the issue
happens when we go from one concurrent
user which is me operating this app
locally to when we have a hundred
concurrent users accessing this app at
the same
time and that problem is underscored by
this plot that I'm going to show you all
right here now for some of you that
aren't familiar with um kind of like
load testing tools for shiny this plot
may be a little bit opaque so let's try
to break it down a little bit so this is
what's known as a session duration plot
and it's showing uh simul 100 simulated
users using the using the shiny app the
ticks along the Y AIS are represent are
basically representing your simulated
users as they go through the workflow on
the previous slide
and then each of these segments that are
moving AC stretching across the x-axis
that's the amount of time that it took a
particular step in that user's
workflow and then we have it's uh sorry
it might be a skinny for those in the
back there's a red line here that is
kind of a reference point that indicates
how long the total workflow took for a
single concurrent user and here for this
workflow is about 93 seconds so there's
two things
that stand out in this plot one is that
we're noticing some inconsistency in
when our users are finishing the
workflow from a ux perspective the same
workflow should take people the same
amount of time if they're accessing the
app at the same time that's just
fair another thing to notice is that the
amount of time that it's taking to go
through this workflow is has gotten
longer and in the worst case we're
seeing that some users are finishing
close to 150 seconds as opposed to the
93 seconds for the one User it's no
bueno so we we have this problem why is
it happening to understand why it's
happening we want to quickly just run
through some Basics about how shiny
works whenever we update one of the
dropdowns in those hexin plots the
browser is going to send a signal over
to R and say hey can you please generate
another plot for me and then R is going
to be like sure buddy I got you and it's
going to generate another PNG which then
the browser goes to render so we have
this nice bidirectional communication
going and that's nice when you have like
just one user like when you're
developing locally and whatnot but this
becomes a problem when you have many
browsers connecting to your app
simultaneously most of the time when you
have your shiny app deployed there's
ultimately a single R process that's
underlying that app and when all of
these browsers are connecting to it that
single R process is doing the brunt of
the work to serve up your plots tables
Etc now R is a very fast language but R
is still a single-threaded language and
so because of that every shiny app out
of the box is going to reach a certain
critical point where the it's the r
process becomes saturated and it
develops a backlog of requests that it
has to mow mow through and that backlog
is what causes that increase in the
session duration that we saw on the plot
earlier so that's you know we have a
sense for what the problem is so what do
we what are we going to do about this
now there's been plenty of talks about
scaling shiny and there's a lot of good
strategies that have come from those we
can cash different assets that's a good
idea we should be doing that if we're
not already there's also asynchronous
operations you know uh writing out files
like large ioe type stuff but that's not
what we're here to talk about we're
talking here to talk about something a
little weirder we're going to talk about
using JavaScript to fix this
problem
um so what's the like use JavaScript
what do we what are we going to do the
the big idea here is that we can scale
our shiny applications by taking work
from that R process that R session and
moving it into the
browser so what does that mean if we
think back to this previous diagram
where all of the browsers are hitting
this R process at the same time like
please give me a plot please give me a
plot please give me a plot we're going
to hand a little differently now we're
going to have R take the data set that's
to be plotted and we're going to have R
kick it out to every connecting browser
and then from there the browser will
become responsible for regenerating the
plots as you update those dropdowns so
it's all happening within those
individual
browsers so that's the idea cool but how
do we pull this off so much like we use
our packages to accomplish different
needs that we have there's some
JavaScript libraries that we need to to
get the job done and so we're going to
need what are we going to need we're
going to need data manipulation Library
something as select columns filter data
aggregate if needed and then we're going
to need a data visualization Library as
well so for the data manipulation
Library I chose duck DBW so you think
like Duck DB W I'm you like what does
all that mean well duck DB if you
haven't heard already it's a database
but it's not just any database I think
of duck DB as like SQL light but for
analytics workloads it's designed from
the ground up to munch through the sort
of queries that our shiny apps love to
love to
send but then what's the wasum part
wasum is a short hand for something
called Web assembly which you can
roughly think of as you know assembly
but tailor made for the browser
um and if those are still kind of like
opaque descriptors the the important
thing about to take away from this slide
is that the synthesis of these two
technologies you take duck DB and web
assembly and you put that in the browser
you get Stupid Fast queries we're not
going to lose any speed in um
manipulating data and whatnot if we move
to the browser which is good sick
even for data visualization I chose
because there's a lot of different uh
JavaScript libraries for visualizing
data so I chose something called
observable plot it's a project that's
built on top of a more mature project
called
d3js um which is known for you know
being able to create any sort of sort of
bespoke data visualization you could
think of now I ultimately chose this one
as opposed to something like D3 for two
reasons one is that look I'm not really
a JavaScript developer like I'm an R
developer primarily and so I'd like for
my JavaScript script library to have as
you know I don't want it to have a very
steep learning curve right so the nice
thing about observable plot is that it's
very similar in spirit to ggplot 2 if we
look at the code samples here on the
left we have you know some Garden
variety ggplot 2 code in R and on the
right is the correspond or the
equivalent code using the observable
plot API and you can see that there's a
lot of good similarities here right um
the whole idea being that in both cases
we have this plot that we're going to be
composing by mapping different you know
attributes of our data set to different
geom that come together to build this
final um you know composition that's the
plot that we're
after sick
awesome so the other thing is that it is
flexible and expressive we all love
ggplot 2 here right we love how it
doesn't limit Us in its ability to
create visualizations and whatnot and I
didn't want to lose that when I moved
from R into the
browser what's fortunate is that
observable plot has a very expressive
API that makes it easy to develop all
the sorts of plots that we're used to
making with GG plots we can have our
Scatter Plots we can have our column
charts we can have our difference plots
that are annotated Every Which Way and
just recently um tool tips have made its
way into the project so that adds
another layer of interactivity that you
can inject into your
visualizations so we're not going to
lose anything there which is
cool so we've refactored our app now
okay so now we are using duck DB wum and
observable plot under the hood and this
is what the result is the main
difference is that we hit this send
button and what that's doing is sending
the data set that's in R over into the
browser and then from there these hex
bin plots that you're seeing that get
generated this is all happening inside
the browser now R isn't doing that
work so we've made these
changes did it do anything right well
this is a story that has a happy ending
fortunately so we did improve on things
and we're going to see that in a new
session duration plot here
so this is the one that we started with
with the first app okay and we notice
that we have our reference duration of
93 seconds and a lot of users are
finishing well past that we don't like
that that's not good well here's where
we're at
now you see this red line on the far
side that's that same reference duration
so that's 93 seconds okay so that's cool
but then it's kind of confusing because
what's all these like little tiny bars
on the left hand side well the important
thing is that those are basically the
operations that are needed to do to kick
the data out into each the individual
browsers from there on in everything's
happening inside the browser so that
line that t that backlog of requests
that forms when you just have like a
typical shiny app out of the box that
Line's gone because everyone's first in
line inside of their own
browser so this has a number of nice
properties for us right we've achieved
upwards of a 40% speed Improvement if
you consider that in the worst case
users were finishing close to about 150
seconds before we've brought that back
down to 93 seconds which is good very
good we've also achieved consistency
because now that all of this is
happening in the browser everyone's
going to be finishing their workflow in
around the same time and again we're
talking about going from one to 100
users and now everybody's finishing in
around the same time with relatively you
know small changes to the code base this
is good
stuff so that's
nice um we get the consistent ux yeah
that's true and then we do get that
dollop of dopamine that you feel you
know when do a good job right you
deliver on what you said you would
that's
cool so we've already talked a little
bit about why this is awesome um but to
kind of like put a bow on it right one
thing that we've done is we found a way
to clear the Prototype Purgatory hurdle
right we all know what this is as shiny
developers you build an app it's great
people like using it but then there's
this does it scale question and stuff
like that that we all have to deal with
well this is a nice solution to
that um in the case here we were able to
successfully scale to 100 users but
there's another thing that I haven't
really touched on yet which is reduced
infrastructure costs and so what am I
what do I mean by that so a lot of the
times when we want to scale shiny
applications what happens is that we
usually resort to uh horizontal scaling
is what you call it right which
basically you have your app and then you
make you know however many copies of it
and then you load balance across each
instance of that application and that is
a good strategy it works but the
consequence is that it usually involves
increased costs on your end to spin up
all that extra compute we don't have to
do that here because we're making
strategic use of all the connecting
browsers that are visiting our
application which is sick we like that
this is all awesome
um all well and good but there's caveats
right so there's always going to be
caveats first is that if you're going to
use a strategy like this browsers are
not servers um don't use them like that
if you start hucking petabytes of data
at people's browsers you're going to
crash them and they're going to be mad
at you so maybe don't do that another
thing is that security still matters
especially if you're in the healthcare
space or anything else that has you you
know sensitive data and things like that
you don't want to necessarily just be
throwing data and exposing it out into
the browser where bad people can do bad
things with it that's not
cool um and then another is that right
now so like this does have some minor
hackery that I did to get this done um I
have a link to the GitHub repo where
this is where you can find this guy at
um it's mostly just like minor changes
to the HTTP UV package just like adds a
mime type for it to accept wasm files
and stuff like that but it's still kind
of annoying to set up up
front
um but those are really much the only
caveats I have go ahead and try it it's
fun and then let me know what you
think um those are my contact details if
you'd like to talk to me more about this
kind of stuff or other data related
things um and then there's the link to
the GitHub repo as well but uh that's
all I have for you guys thanks again for
joining
me
we have time for a couple of questions
awes for for Joe once the first one it's
kind of a cheeky question once you're
using JS libraries Doug DB and wasm what
value is shiny still providing as a web
framework over something like react so I
I love that question right so I think
that what a strategy like this shows is
that you know we with all of these
Technologies it's important to start
thinking about the strategy behind your
application a lot of the ideas that I
brought up like browsers aren't servers
and stuff like that that's part of the
thing that I would respond to with like
why I still think that some things
should still be happening on the r side
like certain data manipulation and
things like that may need to stay on
Prem or like in your own servers and
stuff like that not happening in the
browser um and there's ALS there's other
reasons we could talk about too but I
think that it's more like we're not
looking to replace one thing outright
with the other it's a good Str like
strategic tool to have in your
belt yeah your NE your next question did
you measure how long does it take to
render on the client and can you share
how large your data set was yeah so um
I'd have
to so as far as like how long it took to
render the plots since it's all
happening inside the browser um if we
and I could just like jump back to the
slide real fast so like how long it took
to see the refactored app
um generate the plots that's how fast
it's going to be because it's all
happening in individual browsers there's
no more competing for a single process
as far as how big the data set was um
here it was about
56k
rows I
believe it's like 50s
yes and your last question is uh are
there caveats to keep in mind when
working with different
browsers almost certainly but I'm not
smart enough to speak to that I'm
sorry
yeah stop I'm not I'm not the guy
unfortunately thank thank you Joe thank
[Applause]
you